entreprise
très précise sur qui concerne le chien
de Viking et qui vient en fait
seconde du début de ces questions au
gouvernement c'est l'heure de rejoindre
Quentin Calmet pour parler de l'ordre du
jour de ses questions au Gouvernement
merci beaucoup monsieur d'avoir
participé à sa place effectivement vous
le voyez sur ces images le président
Gérard Larcher qui est en train de
rejoindre l'hémicycle avec les tambours
de la gare de publicaine il va pouvoir
rejoindre l'hémicycles où je me trouve
et où on voit un sous cette image en les
ministres sont en train de discuter ici
à l'intérieur de l'émission vous voyez
Elisabeth borne qui était juste devant
elle attribue voilà qui va être invité à
rejoindre sa place sur le banc des
ministres puisque j'ai un marché rejoint
l'hémicycles on retiendra ce principal
sujet qui va faire l'objet pas moins de
4 questions la crise autour de l'accueil
de lotion Viking un Toulon vendredi
dernier ça va faire donc l'objet de
quatre questions dont la toute première
posée par un président de groupe
politique c'est Hervé Marseille le
président du groupe centriste et vous le
savez lorsque c'est un président de
groupe qui pose une question c'est
toujours la chef du gouvernement qui lui
répond donc dès le début de cette séance
des questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement on va parler de entreprise
et bien autour des relations européennes
c'est parti pour cette séance
[Musique]
nous n'avons pas reçu l'observation
il y en a-t-il en séance
je n'envoie point de procès-verbal est
donc adopté sous les réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues je voudrais saluer la présence
dans notre tribune d'honneur
de Madame martine Biron ministre des
Relations internationales et de la
Francophonie ministre responsable de la
Condition féminine du Québec
elle est accompagnée par le président du
groupe de métier France Québec notre
collègue Rémi Pointreau et la chaleur et
la spontanéité de vos applaudissements
démontrent la qualité de la relation que
nous avons avec le Québec nous lui
souhaitons donc Madame la Ministre la
bienvenue dans notre émission et un
fructueux séjour en France
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues notre ordre du jour rappelle
les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement notre séance est
retransmise en direct sur Public Sénat
et sur notre site internet
chacun sera attentif au respect des uns
et des autres et à celui du temps de
parole je donne immédiatement la parole
au président Hervé Marseille pour le
groupe de l'Union centriste
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
un bateau l'océan Viking a été autorisé
à accoster à Toulon il y a quelques
jours il transportait des migrants
homme-femme enfant et cette situation a
occasionné des débats parfois vifs
souvent passionnés s'agissant d'un
problème extrêmement grave mais aussi
très complexe alors madame la Première
ministre ma première question
c'est quelle est la doctrine de notre
pays est-ce que c'est celle qui a été
exprimée par Monsieur le Président de la
République en 2018 où est-ce que c'est
la jurisprudence Toulon 2022
par ailleurs nos frontières sont
essentiellement européennes
la crise migratoire touche à nos
sociétés c'est un sujet qui constitue
une affaire incandescente pour toutes
nos sociétés européennes
les systèmes qui ont essayé que l'Europe
essayait de mettre en place qu'il
s'agisse du pacte de migration et
d'asile qu'il s'agisse du mécanisme de
solidarité
volontaire ne fonctionne pas ou
fonctionne très mal nous discutons de
moins en moins avec nos amis au sein de
l'Europe nous nous éloignons de l'Europe
nous donnons beaucoup de leçons de
morale aux dirigeants hongrois ou
polonais nous menaçons maintenant les
dirigeants italiens et à l'extérieur
nous sommes en froids avec nos amis
marocains et nous avons des relations
polaires avec beaucoup de pays africains
alors ma seconde question madame la
Première ministre c'est quelle
initiative comprendre votre gouvernement
pour renouer le dialogue et essayer de
trouver des solutions en Europe afin de
mettre des dispositifs efficaces en
place car la crise migratoire c'est une
impasse qui nourrit les populismes et je
ne souhaiterais pas comment Suède comme
en Italie voir mon pays doté d'un tel
gouvernement je vous remercie
merci
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre Madame Elisabeth borne vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le président Hervé
Marseille
depuis plusieurs années les questions
migratoires sont au cœur de l'agenda
européen
malgré ses dangers la Méditerranée
centrale reste la voie la plus empruntée
pour rejoindre l'Union européenne et ces
derniers jours nous avons dû faire face
à l'urgence après trois semaines la
situation aborde le chêne Viking
devenait très préoccupante et appeler
une prise en charge rapide
dans ces circonstances nous avons assumé
pleinement notre devoir humanitaire mais
je vous le confirme monsieur le
Président la France ne dévie pas d'une
approche qui repose sur deux principes
essentiels
des mesures exceptionnelles ont été
prises pour mettre en sécurité ces
personnes
assurer un traitement le plus rapide
possible des demandes d'asile et la
reconduite de ceux qui ne relèvent pas
de l'asile et nous avons constaté que la
solidarité européenne a été au
rendez-vous puisque 11 pays européens
ont accepté d'accueillir des migrants de
lechen Viking et je voudrais devant vous
à nouveau les remercier je veux saluer
l'engagement de nos services publics qui
sont pleinement mobilisés pour apporter
une réponse digne à ces situations
humaines le secrétariat général de la
mer la Marine nationale les préfets
l'OFPRA et la justice
je veux enfin rendre hommage au travail
de la Croix-Rouge française qui a
assumait les premières prises en charge
notre responsabilité collective et de
prévenir le renouvellement de telles
situations
ma conviction c'est que la réponse ne
saurait être seulement nationale mais
doit être aussi européenne
européenne parce qu'un pays ne peut
trouver seul les solutions à ces flux
migratoires
European parce que nous partageons un
même espace l'espace Schengen ce qui se
passe à un endroit de cet espace nous
concerne tous
européenne enfin pour assurer le respect
de deux principes cardinaux en la
matière la responsabilité et la
solidarité
cela suppose un cadre européen avec des
règles qui s'imposent à tous et le
respect des obligations internationales
comme celle du port sur le plus proche
force de constater que l'Italie n'a
respecté ni l'un ni l'autre
concrètement dans ce contexte nous
souhaitons agir dans trois directions
principales d'abord la prévention des
départs irréguliers en provenance
d'Afrique du Nord cela passe par un
renforcement des capacités maritimes des
pays de départ et une plus grande
efficacité collective en matière de
réadmission des migrants en situation
irrégulière ensuite la reprise des
travaux sur les relations avec les ONG
impliquées dans le secours en mer en
Méditerranée ces ONG sauvent des vif ont
un travail important mais une
coopération plus fluide et plus
transparente avec les pouvoirs publics
est indispensable enfin l'actualité
confirme s'il en était besoin la
nécessité d'avancer au plus vite sur la
finalisation du pacte européen pour
l'asile et les migrations nous en avions
fait une priorité lors de la présidence
française et nous avons pu obtenir des
avancées majeures
la présidence check poursuit des
discussions et nous souhaitons qu'un
accord avec le Parlement européen puisse
être rapidement trouvé sur ces sujets
pour conclure nous sommes convaincus que
ces enjeux requiert une discussion
politique c'est pourquoi nous soutenons
l'idée que soit rapidement convoquée à
Bruxelles un conseil extraordinaire des
ministres de l'intérieur afin d'examiner
les réponses concrètes qui peuvent être
rapidement apportées pour traiter le
sujet dans toutes ces dimensions je vous
remercie
monsieur le Président Marseille
la parole notre collègue Jérémy Baki
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen écologiste avait la parole
monsieur le président
Madame mes chers collègues dans quatre
jours démarrera la Coupe du monde de
football que nous pourrions appeler la
Coupe du Monde de la honte jamais une
coupe du monde n'aura générée autant de
malaise corruption des astres
environnementaux droits humains bafoué
si le premier point je ne m'attendrai je
ne m'attarderai pas la justice finira
bien par s'exprimer sur les conditions
d'attribution mais au-delà de ces
conditions il s'agit d'un désastre
écologique en plus de la climatisation
des stades en plein désert nous savons
que ce sont pas moins de 160 vols
quotidiens qui achemineront les
supporters les supporters vers le hôtel
une honte aussi pour les droits des
femmes de LGBT des minorités enfin plus
qu'une honte il s'agit aussi d'une
catastrophe une catastrophe humaine les
travaux pharaoniques ont mobilisé des
milliers de travailleurs migrants
exploités ils ont bâti les stades dans
des conditions insupportables 6500
d'entre eux ont d'ailleurs perdu la vie
alors que cet événement aurait dû être
une fête populaire qui rassemble les
peuples autour d'un sport se révèle être
un véritable désastre un tel scénario ne
peut plus se reproduire ne doit plus se
reproduire que cela soit pour le
football ou d'autres événements sportifs
comme les Jeux asiatiques divers de 2029
qui auront lieu un Arabie Saoudite dans
une région où nous avons que deux jours
d'enneigement par an aussi ne
pensez-vous pas porteur madame la
ministre que la France agisse pour la
création d'une agence internationale
chargée de contrôler l'attribution mais
aussi d'assurer le suivi des grands
événements sportifs selon des critères
de droits humains sociaux et
environnementaux je vous remercie
pour vous répondre ma parole est à la
ministre des Sports des Jeux Olympiques
paralympiques madame houdéac Esterra
vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Baki
la Coupe du monde en effet dès mardi
manches et nos joueurs s'y préparent dur
et depuis longtemps la France comme
d'ailleurs aucun de ses partenaires ne
boycottera cette compétition et j'irai
pour ma part soutenir l'équipe de France
et mon rôle de ministre des Sports 10
000 de nos compatriotes ont également
prévu de se rendre là-bas pour
encourager l'équipe et seront protégés
par nos gendarmes nos policiers français
on croit en la force de l'action
diplomatique et la France œuvre de
manière continue par tous les canaux
pour que tant sur le sujet des droits
humains que sur la question écologique
le Qatar non seulement consolide ses
avancées qui sont d'ailleurs reconnues
par l'OIT par l'ONG Amnesty
International mais surtout les amplifies
sur l'importante question des
travailleurs migrants le Qatar a indiqué
qu'un fonds d'indemnisation existait
déjà et qu'il est disposé à le mobiliser
de mon côté j'ai invité la FIFA à
travailler à la mise en place d'une
contribution financière au titre de
l'héritage de la compétition pour
l'indemnisation des familles et des
travailleurs la FIFA elle-même indiquée
qu'elle s'associerait avec de nombreuses
organisations internationales pour
mettre en avant de grandes causes comme
la lutte contre les discriminations le
développement durable éducation la santé
l'affl ont suivi de mes demandes
d'exemplarité à prix elle-même des
mesures pour s'assurer du respect des
conditions de travail sur le camp de
base de l'équipe de France vous avez vu
la lettre des Bleus qui ont souhaité
rappeler leur attachement au respect de
tous les droits humains et s'engage à
soutenir des ONG qui œuvrent pour leur
protection à travers leurs fonds de
dotation génération 2018 mais vous avez
raison au-delà ce Mondial doit nous
amener collectivement à une plus grande
responsabilité sociétale et à nous
interroger sur le modèle des grands
événements sportifs internationaux que
nous souhaitons ainsi que sur leur
empreinte écologique à cet égard la FIFA
est consciente de cette nécessité pour
l'attribution des prochains Mondiaux de
football et les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 nous montrerons
aussi la voix vous le voyez par de là
les chacun s'engage dans la voie du
nécessaire progrès
une question sur est-ce que la France va
jouer un rôle sur la création d'une
agence internationale serait une bonne
chose vous n'y avez pas répondu j'en
suis désolé que les joueurs ne prennent
pas de décision politique c'est pas
grave le rôle c'est de jouer au football
que les supporters ne prennent pas
d'acte politique ce n'est pas grave leur
rôle c'est une supporter leur équipe
mais que le gouvernement ne prenne pas
la mesure des choses c'est plus
regrettable il n'est pas encore trop
tard madame la ministre on peut avoir
marqué notre attachement droit humain
environnementaux par le port par exemple
d'une tenue dans l'entraînement d'inva
match pour nous qui sommes
paraît-il la nation des droits de
l'homme merci
[Applaudissements]
et donner la parole à notre collègue
Xavier yakovelli pour le groupe de
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre monsieur le ministre
du Travail le président de la République
a fait du plein emploi à horizon 2027 un
thème majeur de sa campagne les chiffres
publiés hier nous montrent que le taux
de chômage continue de baisser et que le
taux d'emploi atteint un niveau record
depuis 1975 malgré les crises que nous
traversons et je vois bien que vous êtes
tous favorables à cette à ces éléments
ces résultats sont encourageants vous
voyez je j'entends vous encouragements
même si les efforts devront être
intensifiés notamment dans les secteurs
en tension mais ma question monsieur le
ministre porte sur l'accès à l'emploi
des personnes en situation de handicap
nous le savons c'est un enjeu est majeur
il est majeur car il concerne 2,7
millions de bénéficiaires qui ont
actuellement une reconnaissance
administrative ou handicap il est majeur
puisqu'il foncièrement liés à notre
volonté de bâtir une société plus
inclusive dans la continuité des
engagements du gouvernement et du
président de la République depuis 2017
il est majeur enfin car on ne peut pas
accepter que le handicap soit un frein à
l'accès à l'emploi des millions de
concitoyens mettant un mal leur
émancipation et leur autonomie face à ce
défi le gouvernement agit et les
premiers résultats sont là le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi en situation de
handicap est à son plus bas niveau
depuis 5 ans et le nombre d'apprentis a
connu une progression de 175 % entre
2019 et 2021 monsieur le ministre le
chemin est encore long la 26e édition de
la Semaine européenne pour l'emploi des
personnes handicapées qui a débuté ce
lundi doit contribuer à changer le
regard du handicap dans l'entreprise
depuis 2018 le duo des constitue un
moment important pour faire tomber les
préjugés et faciliter leur insertion
dans l'emploi dans ce cadre les 30 000
offres d'accueil sont d'autant
d'occasion de créer de nouvelles
opportunités professionnelles et de
créer et de découvrir un environnement
de travail monsieur le ministre à
l'occasion de ce rendez-vous
incontournable pour démystifier le
handicap dans l'entreprise pourriez-vous
nous indiquer quelles sont les pistes
que le gouvernement envisage pour
relever ce défi majeur en termes de
cohésion sociale je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste du travail nous prennent
emploi de l'insertion sur Olivier
Duchamp merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur
vous l'avez dit c'est juste les chiffres
de l'emploi publiés sont de bonne
nouvelle des bonnes nouvelles puisque le
taux de chômage calculé au sens du BIT
et passer de 7,4 à 7,3 % que cela vient
corroborer la création de 84000 emplois
dans le secteur privé au cours du
troisième trimestre et que le taux
d'emploi des Français atteint 68,3%
c'est le meilleur niveau constaté depuis
1975 c'est rassurant puisque dans une
période d'incertitude économique
l'économique continue à créer de
l'emploi et de plus en plus de nos
concitoyens retrouvent un emploi et un
emploi de meilleure qualité puisque la
part des CDI a pour la première fois
depuis 25 ans dépasser les 50% de
l'emploi total c'est aussi une bonne
nouvelle cette marche dans le Pôle
Emploi concerne tout le monde elle
concerne bien évidemment aussi les
travailleurs handicapés le taux de
chômage des personnes handicapées est
passé de 19 à 13% en 5 ans mais il est
encore presque le double du taux de
chômage moyen nous devons continuer à
agir les premiers résultats à constater
sont dû à des engagements pris et mis en
oeuvre la mise en place de référents
handicap dans les entreprises de plus de
250 dans les CFA le fait de garantir les
droits d'accompagner aussi plus
correctement la formation des personnes
handicapées nous souhaitons aller plus
loin et cette semaine européenne de
l'emploi des personnes handicapées et
l'occasion de souligner les efforts que
nous devons encore faire et dans le
cadre de la loi de finance que vous
aurez à examiné nous avons prévu
d'avancer plus avant sur un certain
nombre de sujets les crédits consacrés à
aux Entreprises Adaptées vont passer de
465 à 495 millions d'euros pour
conforter le soutien de l'État aux
Entreprises Adaptées nous allons
reconduire les expérimentations qui
permettent la conclusion de contrat
durée déterminer des tremplins qui
permettent à des personnes en situation
de handicap de passer par une entreprise
adaptée pour aller vers l'économie
ordinaire nous allons aussi reconduire
les crédits consacrés à l'investissement
des esats des ESAT et des entreprises
adaptées pour ce moderniser et
accueillir toujours plus de public enfin
nous allons publier dans les prochains
avec Jean-Christophe Condé j'aime bien
darrusèque un décret qui achèvera la
transformation des esats permettant plus
de fluidité permettant plus de passage
vers l'économie ordinaire et
reconnaissant plus de droits aux
travailleurs dans les esates pour
massimu les accompagner
[Applaudissements]
la parole à notre collègue Jean-Luc
Fichet pour le gros socialiste
écologiste et républicains merci
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
à l'occasion de la Journée
internationale de lutte contre les
violences sexuelles et sexiste le 25
novembre prochain je veux souligner le
caractère malheureusement massif des
violences sexuelles et sexistes en
France comme le relève le rapport annuel
2022 du Haut Conseil à l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes et ceux dans
tous les secteurs je suis politique
médiatique ou professionnel et surtout
les territoires comme la montrer le
rapport chez la torial femme et ruralité
on finit avec les jaunes blanches de
l'égalité 50% des féminicides ont lieu
en ruralité alors que seulement 35% des
femmes y vivent sur le plan économique
les inégalités et discriminations subies
par les femmes se renforcent encore les
femmes sont plus souvent confrontées à
la précarité de l'emploi on assiste au
niveau mondial à un recul vous avez le
droit des femmes elles sont souvent les
premières victimes de la répression des
régimes dictatoriaux on pense aux femmes
afghades et c'est pour cela que les
Iraniennes sont également les premières
mobilisées contre le régime oppresseur
aux États-Unis depuis la décision de la
Cour suprême remettant en cause le droit
à l'IVG les femmes sont en première
ligne pour protester contre ce recul
inacceptable de leurs droits à disposer
de leur corps en France aussi il y a un
risque sur l'accès à l'IVG du fait de la
désertification médicale et de la
pénurie durable des gynécologues
toujours concernant l'IVG je regrette
que la majorité de droite du Sénat est
refusé l'inscription dans la
Constitution du droit d'accès à l'IVG
lorsqu'un droit fondamental des femmes
est attaquée au niveau mondial on attend
de la France qu'elle soit aux
avant-postes pour le défendre le projet
de budget pour 2023 marqué du saut de
l'injustice sociale et de la
précarisation des classes populaires ne
parviendra pas à améliorer la situation
madame la Première ministre quant
allez-vous dégager des moyens
conséquents pour une vraie politique de
lutte contre les violences sexuelles et
sexistes et résoudre enfin les
difficultés quotidiennes vécues par nos
concitoyens je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est quand
même Isabelle Rome ministre délégué
chargé d'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes de la diversité de l'égalité des
chances de la parole monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Fichet je
merci pour votre question oui les droits
des femmes ne sont jamais acquis oui les
droits des femmes demeurent fragiles les
défendre elle combat de ma vie et je
suis fière d'appartenir à ce
gouvernement qui a permis de progresser
comme jamais dans la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes depuis 2017
quatre lois ont été votées pour mieux
les protéger c'est aussi plus 80% de
place d'hébergement d'urgence
160000 policiers et gendarmes formés un
déploiement massif des outils de
protection des victimes les téléphones
graves dangers 300 en 2019 plus de 3400
aujourd'hui les bracelets anti
rapprochement déployés depuis début 2021
près de 1000 actifs aujourd'hui ou
encore la présence d'intervenants
sociaux en commissariat et gendarmerie
416 aujourd'hui
choisissant prochainement sans parler
des 30 centres de prise en charge des
auteurs pour prévenir la récidive grâce
à la majorité parlementaire les
subventions au 39 19 seront aussi
augmentées
5,9 millions d'euros en 2023 soit plus
400 % de puits 2017 s'agissant du budget
de mon ministère il a doublé sous le
précédent quinquennat et augmentera de
15% l'an prochain concernant le droit à
l'IVG que vous évoquez nous soutenons
pleinement avec la première ministre sa
constitutionnalisation elle sera le plus
sûre rempart face aux attaques
d'aujourd'hui ou de demain mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs la France pays
de la Déclaration des droits de l'homme
doit être aussi celui des droits des
femmes face aux montées des
conservatismes notre pays doit rester un
phare pour les libertés de toutes les
femmes vous pouvez sur ma détermination
merci la parole est à notre collègue
c'est fanartado pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre la loi de septembre 2018 pour
la liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel à considérablement
bouleversé le secteur de la formation et
prévoit que le gouvernement adapte ses
dispositions à l'Outre-mer très tôt les
élus ultramarins ont d'ailleurs pointu
du doigt le niveau d'un préparation du
gouvernement face à la mise en oeuvre de
cette réforme sur le versant ultramarin
c'est le cas pour
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon où les acteurs
actuellement sont plus que dans le flou
et je vais m'en expliquer certes les
dispositions législatives et
réglementaires sont arrivés au fil de
l'eau de manière parfois un peu poussive
et on arrive quatre ans après avoir un
dispositif juridique qui commence à se
clarifier pour autant par exemple depuis
4 ans personne sur mon territoire ne
peut faire valoir ses droits de
formation au travers du CPF puisque ça
ne fonctionne pas il semblerait qu'un
blocage technique serait en cours de
réglage de règlement en l'occurrence
pouvez-vous me le confirmer si ce n'est
pas le cas pouvez-vous le faire
instruire au titre de l'équité bien
évidemment de nos concitoyens je vous
demande évidemment la possibilité de
reconstituer les droits à formation
depuis l'existence du CPF puisqu'il n'a
jamais fonctionner sur le territoire de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon depuis sa
création par ailleurs dans l'attente de
la création d'un opro unique un OPCO
guadeloupéen supplée cette carence
locale et depuis juillet 2021 les
partenaires sociaux se sont emparés du
dossier pour créer un OPCO unique
territorial ils ont déposé une demande
d'agrément en juillet 2021 ça fait plus
d'un an qu'ils n'ont aucune nouvelle des
services centraux de l'État sur cette
demande si c'était une demande de
modification des statuts ce mutisme est
totalement anormal depuis plus de six
mois le président de la collectivité
demande au service de l'État la réunion
du cefople banquier l'entité l'instance
qui permet de statuer sur l'ensemble de
ces sujets sans aucune réponse de
service de l'État la situation devient
ubuesque enfin dans la mesure où le
contrat de développement est à
collectivité a été progrogé d'une année
pouvez-vous nous garantir que les
crédits est disponible aujourd'hui sur
la formation professionnelle le choix
également dans ce dispositif quels sont
les garanties que vous pouvez apporter à
mes concitoyens
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement de la formation
professionnelle madame Grandjean vous
avez la parole merci
monsieur terme monsieur le sénateur
Artano nous connaissons effectivement
votre engagement au service de votre
territoire j'ai eu d'ailleurs l'occasion
de participer avec vous par le passé
pour effectivement en défendre les
causes la création d'un OPCO sur votre
territoire et suivi de manière très
attentive par par mon cabinet par mon
ministère par également la direction
générale des outre-mer et la préfète sur
place nous sommes évidemment très
attentifs à la mise en place de ces
dispositifs car vous le savez à la suite
d'un avis du Conseil d'État la
réglementation a applicable en matière
de formation professionnelle et celle du
territoire national il convient donc de
trouver les modalités de mise en oeuvre
pour votre territoire tout en maintenant
un cadre juridique du Code du travail
l'opoko 975 a bien transmis un dossier à
la dgfp et ADG outre-mer à un dossier de
demande d'agrément qui je le rappelle
doit nécessairement satisfaire les
critères de fixés par le décret il y a 8
critères de huit conditionnalités c'est
les services finissent l'examen du
dossier et je peux vous assurer qu'une
réponse va être apportée dans les
prochains jours si l'appareil c'est que
certains points n'étaient pas conformes
au dispositions légales et
réglementaires ou si certaines devaient
être encore précisé les services de
l'État proposeraient un accompagnement
évidemment personnalisé pour finaliser
ce dossier dans les plus brefs délais
car l'objectif de l'État c'est bien sûr
de favoriser l'agrément de l'association
oko 975 dès que cela sera possible et
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le sénateur
acto mais à disposition du territoire
toute son expertise en matière
d'ingénierie de formation et
d'accompagnement des entreprises locales
un accompagnement à la formation
professionnelle doit et bien sûr donc
assurer à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
concernant le CPF je vous confirme que
l'État la case des dépôts et les
organismes socio locaux vont
effectivement finaliser ces travaux et
que toute l'antériorité sera bien
reprise le le contrat est à collectivité
a été renouvelée à l'identique avec des
montants par conséquent maintenu voilà
monsieur le sénateur je pense avoir
répondu à l'ensemble de vos questions
[Applaudissements]
la parole d'un collègue Guy Ménard roche
pour le groupe écologique solidarité
territoire
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Intérieur
après tergiversation et revirement à la
France a accueilli les navires océan de
Vikings qui iraient depuis une vingtaine
de jours au large de nos côtes tant
mieux enfin arrivé ces migrants étaient
pris en charge humainement avec dignité
et on fait l'objet d'entretien
successifs avec les agents de la PAF de
la DGSI de l'OFPRA et parfois les agents
de sécurité du camp j'ai pu observer
dimension place dans cette zone
d'attente temporaire ces entretiens
l'absence d'avocat l'absence de
traducteur sur place les bureaux ouverts
aux quatre vents étant à mal la
confidentialité l'absence de
compréhension par le demandeur d'asile
de ce qui se passait ce contexte dégradé
ne permet pas d'émettre un avis les
premiers entretiens de l'offrey ayant
débuté dimanche ils sont aujourd'hui
terminés hier le ministre de l'Intérieur
a rappelé que le sort était fixé pour
148 personnes 44 MNA 60 acceptés 44
refusés avez-vous des éléments sur la
situation des 86 autres personnes
rescapées hier le ministre de
l'Intérieur a fait des révélations
troublantes annonçant au sujet des 44
personnes c'est en vue refuser le droit
d'entrer routine du demande d'asile elle
sera évidemment reconduite j'ai pris
contact desir avec mes homologues
étrangers à la demande de la première
ministre et du président de la
République quelle étrange chronologique
annonçait par le ministre vous le savez
les migrants qui se voient refuser
l'entrée au titre de la demande d'asile
doivent en être notifié et en droit à un
recours suspensif tant que tous ces
délais ne sont pas expirés ou que le
juge administratif n'a pas statué de
manière définitive ces migrants sont
légalement toujours considérés comme
demandeurs d'asile avant un refus
définitif tout contact avec leur pays
d'origine constitue une violation
Convention de Genève un manquement grave
au respect de la Convention européenne
des droits de l'homme mais pire que tout
il pourrait faire courir de nouveaux
risques pour ces personnes pouvez-vous
madame la mini justifiez donc ses
contacts précipités et contraire aux
droits avec ces pays
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame
Caroline caillot ministre délégué chargé
les collectivités territoriales merci
monsieur le président
et sénateur monsieur le sénateur Guy
benaroche permettez-moi tout d'abord
d'excuser et l'absence du ministre de
l'Intérieur retenue à l'Assemblée
nationale cet après-midi comme vous le
savez le 11 novembre dernier la France a
pris la décision d'accueillir ce bateau
qui naviguette en Méditerranée avec 234
migrants secourus en mer depuis plus de
15 jours
234 personnes en détresse dans 44
enfants déjà accompagné en foyer
d'accueil la décision d'accueillir
l'océan de Viking a été prise à titre
exceptionnel la France a repris à
remplissant devoir avec une triple
exigence d'humanité de sécurité et de
fermeté concernant la situation de ces
234 migrants je peux vous indiquer que
pour le moment les démarches de l'offroy
ne sont pas toutes terminées tout comme
les procédures devant le juge des
libertés et de la détention également il
nous est donc difficile
de vous communiquer des chiffres
définitifs à ce stade je peux vous
confirmer néanmoins qu'à leur arrivée
toutes les mesures ont été prises afin
d'apporter l'assistance sanitaire et
médicale nécessaire au passagers ils ont
ensuite été placés dans une zone
d'attente chacun d'entre eux fait
l'objet d'un entretien individuel de
sécurité avec les services spécialisés
ainsi que d'un entretien administratif
vous l'avez rappelé avec l'OFPRA en ce
qui concerne les personnes qui peuvent
obtenir l'asile elles seront accueillies
partout en Europe ce qui prouve bien
comme l'a dit la première ministre il y
a quelques instants que la solution est
européenne et nous tenons à remercier
nos partenaires de cette solidarité la
France a d'ailleurs demandé la tenue
dans tous les dans les tous prochains
jours d'une réunion européenne à un
niveau ministériel afin de traiter des
suites de cette affaire
dans la mini j'ai pas une réponse dans
mes deux questions mais je vous le
répète accueillir dignement c'est à
cuire dans les règles et dans le respect
des procédures accueillez dignement ce
n'est pas se réjouir et se féliciter
d'avoir fait preuve d'humanité et en
même temps publier des arrêtés
préfectoraux interdisant les
distributions de repas à Calais après
avoir été contraint de mettre en place
des points d'eau accueillir en face et
secourir en Méditerranée comme en Manche
et comme dans les Alpes
[Applaudissements]
des indépendants République et
territoire
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues il nous faut
reprendre le fil de la grande aventure
du nucléaire civile en France disait en
février dernier le président de la
République la guerre en Ukraine et la
remontée du prix des hydrocarbures ont
fini de convaincre ceux qui doutaient de
la nécessité de poursuivre le
développement de notre filière nucléaire
française
l'Allemagne fait ainsi face à de graves
difficultés pour n'avoir pas su
diversifier suffisamment son mix
énergétique elle peut aujourd'hui au
prix fort ça dépendante au gaz russe et
son abandon de l'atome la France est
dans une meilleure posture même si elle
doit faire face aux conséquences d'un
certain nombre d'erreurs d'appréciation
et d'anticipation
plus personne ne doute à présent que le
nucléaire est l'une des principales
composantes d'un mix énergétique
souverain pour garantir à nos
concitoyens et à nos entreprises une
énergie fiable et abordable il convient
de moderniser notre part
veillez à la remise en état des
réacteurs affectés par le phénomène de
corrosion sous contrainte est une chose
mais la France doit aussi renforcer son
parc existant en se dotant de nouveaux
réacteurs à cet égard de nombreux
territoires de monta accueillir ces
nouvelles installations c'est le cas de
la ville de Nogent-sur-Seine dans mon
département de l'Aube dont le site conçu
pour quatre réacteurs à binicio n'en
accueillent aujourd'hui que deux alors
qu'un projet de loi nucléaire est en
préparation nos territoires ont besoin
de réponses quant au calendrier au
critères d'éligibilité des sites et plus
généralement madame la ministre quand on
modalités de sélection des projets
pouvez-vous madame la ministre nous
apporter quelques éclaircissements sur
ces questions et m'indiquer si un site
comme celui de Nogent-sur-Seine
relèverait d'une liste d'une liste
prioritaire je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre de la transition énergétique
madame panière une acier
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Paoli Gaga vous avez raison de
le dire nous allons reprendre le fil de
la grande aventure du nucléaire civile
nous le faisons pour notre indépendance
énergétique pour le pouvoir d'achat des
Français pour la compétitivité des
entreprises et nous le faisons
évidemment pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique c'est dans cet
optique que nous avons conclu dès 2019
un contrat stratégique pour la filière
nucléaire et engager un demi milliard
d'euros pour moderniser cette filière
dans le cadre du plan de relance nous
avons demandé à EDF en février dernier
de préparer le lancement de scie d'une
tranche d'une série de 6 premiers EPR
EDF a recommandé sur la base des
critères qui seront utilisés pour
l'ensemble de ces programmes si trois
sites ces critères se sont le foncier
disponibles l'étude des sols la
possibilité de raccordement en réseau de
transport les possibilités de
refroidissement des critères qui sont
techniques évidemment l'engagement des
élus locaux l'acceptabilité des
populations joue un grand rôle mais je
vois reconnaître que sur ce sujet là
beaucoup aujourd'hui de sites existants
sont extraordinairesment motivés pour
accueillir un nouveau site nucléaire EDF
a recommandé de retenir en premier lieu
en ligne et Gravelines continuent à
étudier budget et Tricastin pour la
troisième série et remet à l'étude 8
sites complémentaires dans la
perspective d'équilibrer notre mix
énergétique le débat public a commencé à
Penly l'enjeu c'est d'être prêt au
moment où vous voterez la loi climat
énergie qui viendra préciser notre mix
énergétique vous aurez alors toutes les
solutions sur la table le débat public
sera lancé le délégué nouveau-nucléaire
qui vient d'être nommé aura l'occasion
de mettre en musique l'ensemble des
services de l'État pour soutenir le
nouveau patron de DF dans ce projet
industriel extraordinaire et c'est à ce
moment là que nous aurons très
exactement la trajectoire qui sera
soumise à la représentation nationale
l'objectif avoir nos premiers réacteurs
en 2037
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
j'aurais bien aimé avoir le nom des huit
sites auxquels vous renvoyez dans votre
réponse
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Michel bonus pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adressait au ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer monsieur le ministre
vendredi dernier l'océan Viking a
accosté dans le port de Toulon
à son bord 230 migrants dont une
cinquantaine de mineurs secouru en mer
entre la Libye et l'Italie depuis des
semaines ce bateau naviguait sans
destination l'Italie refusait très
fermement de l'accueillir passant outre
les conventions européennes la France a
dû se résoudre à l'accueillir pourtant
d'autres voix allant humanité dignité
soutient et fermeté était possible
monsieur le ministre vous annonciez
vouloir réguler les flux migratoires
vous annoncez aussi des négociations
pour convaincre l'Italie d'accueillir le
navire alors qu'il était clair que ce
nouveau gouvernement refuserait
finalement vous avez ordonné sur
l'accueil et vous avez ouvert la voie au
passeur
l'accueil de ce navire et la gestion de
ces migrants crée un précédent d'une
grande gravité par votre manque de
préparation et d'anticipation des vis de
procédure ont été soulevées par le
manque de moyens que vous accordez la
justice leur citation leur situation n'a
pas pu être examiné dans les temps la
conséquence c'est comment je vous parle
des migrants sont libres sans que leur
situation n'est été examinée faute de
moyens légaux la rétention des mineurs
ont déjà fugué votre incapacité à
intervenir surtout à anticiper les
difficultés mais gravement en cause la
responsabilité du gouvernement votre
prédécesseur jean-coulomb nous apprend
qu'il a préféré démissionner plutôt que
de se voir imposé par le Président de la
République la création d'un grand centre
d'accueil de migrants dans la ville de
Toulon et de générer ce genre de
situation et ses inquiétudes pour les
habitants de Toulon et du Var
évidemment nous serons jamais insensible
à la souffrance des enfants des femmes
ou des hommes qui recherchent l'asile
mais ne voyez-vous pas mais ne
voyez-vous pas que dans nos territoires
déjà fragilisés et qui manquent que le
moyen nous sommes aujourd'hui incapables
de les assumer nous ne voulons pas que
nos côtes deviennent de nouvelles cibles
privilégiées pour les passeurs ma
question est la suivante monsieur le
ministre qu'allez-vous faire si de
nouveaux bateaux se présente à quoi les
toulonner et les Français dont
quand on veut répondre la parole
regarde des choses ministre de la
Justice monsieur Dupont-Moretti
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur au fond la réponse est assez
simple
il était de notre honneur
d'accueillir ces migrants et notamment
les 44 enfants qui se trouvaient en mer
depuis 15 jours
ça s'appelle tout simplement l'humanisme
dont la France sonore depuis des siècles
et qui fait son universalité
j'ai presque envie ça n'est pas le lieu
de vous poser directement la question
mais alors monsieur le sénateur que
fallait-il faire à compter du moment où
les Italiens priez de les accueillir ne
les ont pas accueillies alors vous
évoquiez la justice et ses moyens le
tribunal judiciaire de Toulon s'est
mobilisé pour multiplier le nombre de
JLD pour multiplier le nombre de membres
du parquet pour traiter immédiatement et
dans l'urgence de ces dossiers les
décisions ont été rendues certaines font
l'objet d'un appel vous le savez la
séparation des pouvoirs m'interdits de
commenter les décisions qu'allons-nous
faire pour l'avenir et bien nous battre
pour que chaque pays européen prenne sa
part je voudrais vous rappeler que
durant la dernière campagne
présidentielle
un éminent représentant de l'extrême
droite voyant les images de migrants
Macé à la frontière polonaise a dit
qu'il fallait les laisser crever de
froid ça n'est pas l'option du
gouvernement auquel j'ai l'honneur
d'appartenir
la parole est à notre collègue Henri
Leroy pour le gros les républicains
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
première Mini chère collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur en 2018 la
France refusait d'accueillir les 629
migrants de l'Aquarius la même année à
l'Assemblée générale des Nations unies
le président de la République disait
préféré une mobilité internationale
choisie et non subit au risque de faire
monter les extrêmes on connaît la suite
de l'histoire vendredi dernier manuel
Macron donné l'ordre d'accueillir 230
migrants de l'océan Viking à Toulon
madame les ministres la France ne peut
pas accueillir toute la misère du monde
dans notre pays beaucoup de personnes
français étrangers assimilés en la plus
grande difficulté pour se nourrir se
loger se soigner demain pour se chauffer
bref pour survivre on accueillant
l'océan viking
vous confondez humanitaire et appelle
d'air en accueillant l'océan Viking vous
faites le jeu des passeurs sauvez des
vies en péril est une priorité mais les
bateaux de passeurs doivent être envoyés
dans les ports de départ il est urgent
que la France reprenne le contrôle de
ses frontières il est urgent qu'il y ait
une refonte de la politique
d'immigration au niveau européen
autrement vous continuerez à dénaturer
la France et à mettre les Français en
danger oui il existe un lien entre
immigration et insécurité dame la
ministre combien faudra-t-il de Bataclan
de caramel de massacres Nice de Lola
pour que vous puissiez enfin la mesure
du destin qui se joue sous les yeux
qu'attendez vous ces lois risquez
d'accueillir sont de l'isote ne veulent
pas et pour expulser tous ceux qui n'ont
pas vocation à être sur le sol national
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Véran mais il délégué
porte-parole du gouvernement
merci Monsieur le merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateurs il est
certaine question auxquelles lorsqu'on
est ministre et qu'on doit répondre on
se dit qu'il y a énormément de sénateurs
de tout bord qui aimerait vous répondre
à ma place
vous dire que votre question est
choquante monsieur le sénateur c'est
c'est un euphémisme comme dit
l'excellent garde des sceaux
en quoi Monsieur le Sénateur êtes-vous
habilité êtes-vous fondé à faire le lien
entre quelques dizaines de personnes en
détresse en Méditerranée une partie
venant du Bangladesh une cinquantaine
d'enfants mineurs des enfants de moins
de 3 ans et les attentats du Bataclan
qui essayez-vous monsieur le sénateur
d'un système
je ne crois pas je parle sous le
contrôle de votre président de groupe
que je connais suffisamment pour savoir
que ça ne peut pas être la ligne de la
droite républicaine de notre pays que
celle de faire le lien entre le
terrorisme et le sauvetage en mer de
personnes qui si on les avait pas
accueillies en France aurait fini
monsieur le sénateur par périr en mer
monsieur le sénateur je ne sais pas si
vous êtes amené à faire du bateau si ça
vous arrive pendant les vacances ou
autre mais j'ai une conviction malgré la
question que vous avez posée c'est que
si un jour vous deviez vous trouver à
côté d'un esquif en pleine mer avec sur
cette esquive des personnes à bord et
qui sont en train de se noyer je ne
crois pas que vous les regarderiez les
bras croisés en disant vous n'avez pas
le place sur notre territoire vous
viendriez évidemment les aider et bien
la France peut se norgueillir de faire
ce travail que chaque citoyen ferait à
sa place chaque citoyen ferait à sa
place la non-assistance à personne en
danger n'est pas dans l'ADN de la France
n'est pas dans l'ADN de la République et
du pays des Lumières monsieur le
sénateur
ne faites pas d'amalgame
la France conservera sur le territoire
national un tiers des personnes qui
pourront disposer du droit d'asile ou
que sont légitime pour le demander
toutes les conditions de surveillance de
sécurité sanitaire avec les contrôles au
port militaire de Toulon ont été mis en
place vous êtes en train de faire une
généralité et je trouve que c'est assez
grave après les élections plus avant
connues alors qu'il y a une montée du
populisme en Europe et je crois que
c'est pas ce qu'attendent de nous les
français
la parole est à notre collègue Annie le
héros pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste qui a républicain
monsieur le ministre de la santé et de
la prévention souvent tabou les troubles
psychiques concernent 13 millions de
personnes un Français sur cinq en
souffre il s'agit du premier poste de
dépenses de l'assurance maladie devant
les cancers la souffrance psychique
conduit à 200 000 tentatives de suicide
en France chaque année et 9000
issus fatales soit un taux de suicide
parmi les plus élevés d'Europe nombreux
décès sont évitables Agnès bussin
ministre de la Santé reconnaissait en
2017 je cite l'abandon de la psychiatrie
5 ans après rien n'a changé monsieur le
ministre vous avez la responsabilité de
la santé et aussi de la prévention un
repérage précoce et une prise en charge
adaptée améliorait la qualité de vie des
patients vous me direz que depuis 2022
l'assurance maladie rembourse les
consultations de psychologues dès l'âge
de 3 ans c'est une avancée mais elle est
loin d'être à la hauteur des attentes
par en pauvres de la médecine
aujourd'hui sinistrée la psychiatrie
publique manque d'argent et d'effectif
30% des postes de psychiatre
hospitaliers sont vacants les postes
d'infirmiers n'ont pourvu ont doublé
entre 2019 et 2022 le PLFSS 2023
n'apporte aucune mesure pour sortir la
psychiatrie de cette situation le nombre
de patients augmente et augmentera suite
au covid leur prise en charge se dégrade
l'usage des psychotropes et des mesures
de contention augmente et sont dénoncés
par les médecins eux-mêmes qui n'ont pas
d'autre choix les soignants sont en
grande difficulté des enfants et leurs
parents souffrent du manque
d'accompagnement alors que les files
d'attente s'allonge dans les centres
médico-psychologiques et
médico-psychopédagogiques depuis des
années les professionnels tirent la
sonnette d'alarme ils sont à bout
monsieur le ministre quelle est la
stratégie du gouvernement pour répondre
aux besoins de soins urgents en
psychiatrie public notamment pour les
enfants et adolescents quel est votre
projet de prévention sur le long terme
pour les maladies psychiques
on vous répond de la parole au milieu de
la santé et de la prévention
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice le héros les
personnels de psychiatrie exerce dans
des conditions difficiles conditions qui
se sont encore accentuées nous le savons
tous à l'issue de la crise covid avec
une augmentation de la détérioration de
la santé mentale et ce qui est plus
inquiétant comme vous le dites c'est la
santé également des enfants et je veux
déjà rendre hommage au travail qui est
fait par l'ensemble de ses
professionnels
la volonté de ce gouvernement va volonté
vous le savez c'est que nos concitoyens
et tous accès à la prévention aux soins
c'est l'objet de l'engagement et c'est
l'objet de la refondation et des la
réforme que je souhaite conduire
concernant la psychiatrie plusieurs
choses ont déjà été faites à l'issue des
Assises de la psychiatrie de la
sentimentale qui se sont déroulées
l'année dernière et dont nous allons
faire le bilan très protègement très
très protégé prochainement excusez-moi
le dispositif mon psy montre tout son
intérêt l'accès vous l'avez dit à des
psychologues cliniciens la mise en place
du numéro national de prévention du
suicide des enveloppes financières
conséquentes et pérennes ont été mises
en place depuis 2018 elle se prolonge
encore dans les années qui viennent et
le Ségur investissement est aussi à
destination bien entendu des
établissements de psychiatrie qui
doivent être réformés de façon plus
structurelle la psychiatrie subie les
mêmes problèmes que l'hôpital
d'attractivité et de perte de sens là
aussi les solutions mises en place dans
secondaires en particulier pour
l'hôpital seront bénéfiques pour la
psychiatrie sur le plan structurel il y
a plusieurs problèmes et deux combats
amener un combat au niveau territorial
pour travailler sur le maillage le
service d'accès aux soins des soins non
programmés d'attractivité c'est ce qui
est fait dans le cadre des CNR
territoriaux et un combat aussi au
niveau national ou plusieurs chantiers
sont en cours le développement des IPA
plus d'accès et plus facile aux
psychologues la réforme du financement
pour une équité entre les territoires la
réforme des autorisations pour améliorer
le maillage du territoire sur le cas
particulier de la pédopsychiatrie nous
l'avons intégré aux travaux en cours
avec les professionnels sur la santé de
l'enfant et la pédiatrie et nous
apporterons une feuille de route au
début du printemps je vous remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
François bonhomme pour le groupe des
Républicains
monsieur le ministre depuis plusieurs
semaines le Comité de Prévention de la
radicalisation vous a mis en garde
contre des appels répétés de la mouvance
islamiste visant à contourner la loi de
2004 loi qui vous le savez interdit les
signes religieux à l'école cette
mouvance encourage en particulier les
jeunes filles via les réseaux sociaux à
porter des vêtements à connotation
religieuses 720 signalements d'atteintes
au principe de laïcité dans les écoles
ont été relevées par vos propres
services depuis la rentrée scolaire une
vingtaine de jeunes filles portaient la
Baya au lycée Bourdel de Montauban la
semaine dernière nous avons un prix
qu'une enseignante de ce lycée a été
placé sous protection de policière après
avoir fait une remontrance et une élève
sur sa tenue
j'ajoute que cet élève a ensuite publié
une vidéo de la scène à l'insu de sa
professeur monsieur le ministre face à
ses dérives répétées en Montauban comme
ailleurs allez vous clairement indiquer
que le port de la Baya est une atteinte
délibérée au principe de laïcité et n'a
pas sa place à l'école
pour vous répondre la parole aux
ministres de l'Éducation nationale mais
de la jeunesse du superbendaï
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur François bonhomme la situation
du lycée de Montauban que vous évoquez à
l'instant et suivi de prêt par le
ministère le rectorat en lien également
avec la préfecture du Tarn et Garonne
que s'est-il passé avant les vacances il
y avait une vingtaine de lycéennes qui
portait des abayas la direction du lycée
à engagé une procédure qui commence par
des échanges avec les élèves concernés
et avec les familles qui ont amené 16 de
ces lycéennes à renoncer à porter ce
vêtement intention religieux à la
rentrée il en restait quatre trois
d'entre elles ont renoncé depuis
quelques jours et il en restait une
particulièrement
radicale je dirais et c'est elle qui a
été impliquée dans l'incident que vous
évoquez le proviseur ainsi que la
professeur en question ont porté plainte
une protection fonctionnelle a été
accordée et la direction a travaillé en
bonne intelligence avec la préfète du
Tarn et Garonne la situation pour
l'instant nous la surveillons de près
bien entendu en ce qui concerne ce lycée
mais cette situation et celle-ci à leur
actuelle nous gardons une grande
vigilance sur la question à propos de
ces abayas il y a une loi c'est la loi
de 2004 et le législateur avait
précisément prévu que différentes
itérations de vêtements à intention
religieuse pourrait se produire par la
suite le caractère de cette loi c'est
que c'est une loi à dimension générale
qui s'applique à de multiples situations
et par conséquent nous notre boussole
c'est de faire observer la loi la
laïcité elle exige du discernement elle
exige du sang-froid exige de la fermeté
c'est ce que nous faisons pas besoin
d'effet de manches pour cela
Monsieur Bonhomme
monsieur le ministre j'avais un l'espoir
que vous ayez une position un peu plus
clair et ferme par rapport à ma question
malheureusement vous avez fait une
réponse tout à fait ordinaire j'allais
dire administrative ce que je ne connais
pas pourquoi parce que ceux qui se passe
à Montauban se passe ailleurs
figurez-vous vous le savez parfaitement
d'ailleurs et je comprends très bien
qu'on a comme un dialogue pour essayer
de par filtre successifs de réduire le
nombre de personnes concernée mais au
bout d'un moment il faut prendre une
position claire et cette position claire
vous ne l'avez pas prises monsieur mind
c'est bien le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui cette situation via le
réseau sociaux va se reproduire se
reproduire régulièrement vous n'avez
jamais posé un interdit par rapport à
cela et la situation est grave puisque
je rappelle que c'est pas un fait divers
d'ailleurs vous aviez dit dans une
interview il faut pas généraliser mais
là c'est simplement il y a une masse
critique en quelque sorte de la
situation et c'est pas sous l'un des
faits divers qu'il faut l'aborder je me
semble-t-il c'est sous l'angle d'une
position ferme et définitive sur cette
problème qui va revenir nécessairement
donc monsieur le ministre on attend de
vous une réponse ferme durable
précisément pour que l'école soit un
lieu d'émancipation à l'abri de toute
pression merci
à part
Levy pour le groupe de l'Union santé
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
votre prédécesseur sur les leçons à
tirés du tragique assassinat de Samuel
Paty dans nos commémorions il y a un an
il y a un mois le triste anniversaire ma
question aujourd'hui rejoint est celle
de mon collègue François bonhomme
département de Tarn-et-Garonne mais le
sujet est suffisamment important pour
qu'on s'y attarde
vous en doutez bien l'affaire de la
bagarre du lycée Antoine Bourdel de
Montauban a très profondément choqué le
consignant monsieur le ministre
circulaire du 9 novembre dernier est
supposé éclairé l'application de la loi
de 2004 sur la laïcité à l'école
malheureusement le constat tous les
jours dans les établissements c'est
circulaire n'est enseignants et chef
d'établissement souvent bien seul face à
des phénomènes de revendication
religieuses et de radicalisation en
particulier face à de nouvelles manières
d'affirmer son identité culturelle et
religieuse dans la Bayern et imparfait
exemple qu'est-ce que la bagarre il
s'agit d'une longue robe qui recouvre
tout le corps sauve la tête et les mains
bien qu'il ne soit pas originellement de
nature religieuse ne soyons panaïf son
usage n'est clairement aujourd'hui la
loi de 2004 il se pose qu'à l'école le
port de Sinou tenu par lesquels les
élèves manifestent ostensiblement
inappartenance religieuse est interdit
quelle est la doctrine de l'éducation
nationale sur la Baya regarde la loi
n'avez pas répondu monsieur le ministre
est-elle considéré comme une
manifestation ostensible d'appartenance
religieuse
malgré les précisions de la ministre
déléguée à la citoyenneté sur ce sujet
rien n'est clair de plus incident de
Montauban pose une fois encore le
problème de la formation et de la
protection du corps enseignant surtout
au regard du danger représenté par les
smartphones et les réseaux sociaux
véritable condensateurs de haine et de
violence monsieur le ministre la
formation comporte-t-elle des mises en
situation concrète notamment pour les
contrats actuels leur apprend-t-on à
réagir face à de telles provocations et
agressions et sur la protection a-t-on
finalement réellement avancé depuis
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty je remercie
pour vous répondre la parole des
communistes de l'éducation nationale et
la jeunesse
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Lévy je vous repère plus
excusez moi voilà pardon
en effet les chiffres de signalements
traduisent trois phénomènes le premier
vous l'avez mentionné c'est celui des
réseaux sociaux avec des challenges et
des défis qui se multiplient depuis le
mois de septembre nous avons une
difficulté nous sommes en échange avec
les responsables des réseaux sociaux à
propos de modération parce que nous
critiquons la lenteur et la faiblesse de
la modération mais il faut avouer que
sur ce terrain là nos armes juridiques
sont limitées je mets en garde bien
entendu les élèves contre ces
influenceurs de mauvaise aloi le
deuxième phénomène c'est comme l'année
dernière l'hommage à Samuel Paty qui
s'accompagne toujours malheureusement de
contestation le troisième phénomène
c'est notre vigilance accrue et le que
nous faisons remonter de la part des
rectorats tous les signalements de
manière à produire des chiffres mensuels
j'ai décidé une production de chiffre
mensuels ce qui permet de faire de ces
données un outil de pilotage plutôt que
de les avoir plusieurs semaines plus
tard à propos de cette loi de 2004
pourquoi ne faut-il pas préciser le type
de vêtements et conserver le principe de
la loi parce que nous nous aventurons
dès lors sur un terrain juridique
extrêmement complexe d'un point de vue
juridique la Bayane est pas simple à
définir nous serions contournés la
semaine suivante par une longueur
d'Europe par une forme de colle par tel
ou tel accessoire qui prolongerait de
semaine en semaine et multiplierait les
circulaires et nous emmènerait
directement au tribunal administratif et
nous perdrions tribunal administratif
par conséquent là le principe c'est
celui de la loi de 2004 qui doit être
appliquée avec fermeté et avec sang
froid
Monsieur Lévy
les enseignants c'est une réponse claire
la circulaire que vous avez donné de 9
novembre n'est pas clair alors
finalement quand je vous écoute
peut-être que la solution finalement à
Bahia ou pas ce serait peut-être de
porter l'uniforme pourquoi pas
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Pascal
Alizard pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous avons bâti une
partie de la dernière loi de
programmation militaire sur le paradigme
de la coopération européenne et plus
particulièrement de la coopération
franco-allemande c'était effectivement
une opportunité qu'il fallait saisir
néanmoins ce volontarisme dans la France
a fait preuve se heurte aux dieux
réalité de la politique de l'industrie
et des intérêts et depuis de longs mois
les signaux sont inquiétants sur divers
projets qui s'accumulent l'avion de
combat le char l'avion de patrouille
maritime et les forces armées
s'interrogent comme d'ailleurs les
industriels et comme les parlementaires
sur le calendrier les conditions et
désormais sur l'aboutissement ou pas de
ces différents projets en ce qui
concerne l'avion de combat nous arrivons
dans une phase où chacun attend des
garanties de l'État en matière de
maîtrise d'ouvrage de maîtrise d'oeuvre
par Dassault Aviation de prise en compte
des besoins spécifiques de nos de
protection de la propriété
intellectuelle sur les technologies
françaises ou de cadres d'exportation
alors madame la ministre ma question est
simple quels engagement prenez-vous sur
ces différents sujets et qu'en est-il du
Plan B en cas d'échec de la coopération
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
secrétaire d'État chargé des anciens
combattants de la mémoire vous avez la
parole
monsieur le sénateur Alizard
permettez-moi d'abord d'excuser le
ministre des armées qui est retenu par
ailleurs sur le SCAS je vous remercie
d'aborder ce sujet important pour nos
armées et pour la France qui fait
l'objet d'ailleurs des débats réguliers
au Parlement je pense que nous devons
d'abord nous concentrer sur les faits
premier effet la France aura besoin d'un
avion de combat du futur parce que notre
armée est une armée d'emploi parce que
nous attendons rester dans la course
technologique et parce que ce système
d'avion mais aussi de combat je le
rappelle qui appartiendra aux forces
aériennes stratégiques
sera déterminant pour notre dissuasion
la France est donc engagée dans le Scaff
parce qu'elle y trouve son intérêt avec
les partenaires allemands et je le
rappelle espagnol
autre fait Dassault avion est clairement
le leader de l'avion de combat au sein
de du programme Scaff dans la logique
réaffirmée par nos partenaires du
meilleur athlète nous restons attentifs
sur ce point dans la durée quelle est la
situation au moment où nous nous parlons
nous devons aujourd'hui donner sa chance
à la phase 1 B comme vous en avez parlé
du projet Skaf cette phase un B consiste
au démarrage de la phase de
démonstration du projet les divergences
entre les industriels ce sont désormais
largement estompés comme l'a indiqué
publiquement Éric Rapier et Guillaume
euphory l'accord entre les industriels
et très proches du côté de des états la
France qui pilote le projet souhaite
maintenant notifier le contrat aux
industriels nous sommes en attente d'une
consommation de nos partenaires
allemands et espagnols sur ce point
l'objectif est que les contrats soient
signés dès le mois de décembre au-delà
de la phase 1 B nous continuerons à
préserver les intérêts stratégiques de
la France tant ce qui concerne
l'élaboration que l'exportation du Scaff
c'est important pour l'exportation car
en signant des accords de défense c'est
la parole de la France que nous
engageons vous le savez le ministre des
armées est particulièrement attentif sur
ce point pour finir donc comme le
ministre des Armées l'affirmé à
plusieurs reprises il s'agit pas d'une
affaire idéologique sur le point Franco
sur le couple franco-allemand il y aura
quoi qu'il en soit un avion de chasse
pour succéder au rafales dans l'armée
française
[Applaudissements]
des Françaises représente des
compétences uniques madame la ministre
vous le savez non délocalisable des
entreprises allant des startups au grand
groupe et nous devons collectivement
préserver ses emplois dans nos
territoires c'est savoir faire qui une
fois perdu seraient très difficile à
récupérer nos armées ont besoin du Scaff
en tout cas ils ont besoin d'un avion de
chasse pour garantir la supériorité dans
les futurs opérations et dans un monde
où les avions de combat les drones
évoluent très vite de même que les
défenses antiériennes nous avons donc
besoin du futur avion de combat pour la
continuité de la dissuasion et de
l'aéronavale et enfin nous devons
pouvoir continuer à exporter et ça c'est
important aussi auprès de pays amis
alliés sans contrainte extérieures c'est
un des sujets avec l'Allemagne je me
permets d'insister nous avons en France
des procédures d'exportation qui me
semblent-ils sont robuste est suffisante
et efficace merci
la parole est à notre collective il
m'arrive pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre des comptes publics
dans un communiqué du 8 novembre dernier
la Commission de régulation de l'énergie
a annoncé que les producteurs d'énergie
renouvelables allaient reverser 30,9
milliards d'euros au budget de l'État
dans le cas de la contribution au
service public de l'électricité cette
contribution est exceptionnelle c'est la
première fois que ce n'est pas l'état
qui compense les charges services
publics de l'énergie mais qui encaisse
des recettes exceptionnelles et
inattendue puisque les prévisions
initiales envisager une dépense de 8
milliards pour l'État soit un
différentiel de près de 40 milliards
d'euros cette inversion de tendance et
ses 30,9 milliards de recettes qui en
découlent s'expliquent par
l'augmentation des prix de gros
l'électricité par rapport au tarif
garanti par l'État dans le contexte
énergétique et géopolitique que nous
connaissons à elle seule la filière de
l'éolien terrestre parfois contraignante
pour les communes et leurs habitants
apportent une contribution de 21,7
milliards comme l'indique la creux dans
sa communication ces recettes
supplémentaires devront financer le
bouclier tarifaire alors que les élus
locaux sont en première ligne face à
l'explosion des prix d'énergie des
matières premières et de l'inflation
comptez-vous utiliser concrètement cette
manne financière pour soutenir les
collectivités territoriales je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
des communistes délégué chargé des
comptes publics
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Didier Marie vous
l'avez rappelé nous avons en France un
système contribution au service public
de l'électricité qui consiste à avoir
signé des contrats avec les
énergéticiens du renouvelable en
garantissant un prix qui revenait pour
l'État à subventionner les énergéticiens
en leur versant la différence entre le
prix de marché et ce prix qui permettait
de donner une rentabilité à leurs
investissements sauf évidemment avec la
crise que nous connaissons et l'envoler
des prix de l'électricité le prix du
marché se retrouve au dessus de ce prix
qui avait été conclu et les contrats
prévoient effectivement que les
énergéticiens reversent à l'état le
surplus au dessus du prix qui avait été
conclu et j'en remercie d'ailleurs le
Parlement qui a voté cet été une mesure
pour déplafonner ces contrats puisque
certains d'entre eux prévoyaient que ce
qui était reversé à l'État était
plafonné à quoi servent ces fonds qui
sont aujourd'hui reversés à l'état
monsieur le sénateur il servent à
financer le bouclier et tarifaire qui
permet de contenir la facture
d'électricité des français une partie du
bouclier tarifaire puisque la réalité
c'est qu'en 2023 le bouclier tarifaire
nous coûtera 47 milliards d'euros et que
quand on défalque ce que nous récupérons
avec la fameuse CSPE il reste 16
milliards d'euros net de dépenses pour
le bouclier tarifaire donc vous voyez
bien que ce que nous récupérons des
énergéticiens au titre de ces contrats
ne fait que prendre en compte une partie
seulement du bouclier tarifaire
évidemment que nous allons continuer à
accompagner les collectivités locales
dans le cadre de la crise de l'inflation
et de l'envoler des prix de l'énergie
cet après-midi nous démarrons les débats
budgétaires sur le PLFR puis sur le PLF
je sais qu'ils seront nourris vous le
savez un certain nombre de mesures ont
été actées à l'Assemblée nationale
seront je crois enrichi renforcés
préciser clarifier au Sénat notamment le
filet de sécurité que nous prévoyons
pour 2023 un milliard 500 millions
d'euros qui sont budgétés et j'attends
beaucoup des travaux que nous aurons
ensemble et les débats que nous aurons
ensemble sur les précisions que nous
pourrons donner à à dispositif je ne
rappelle pas ce qui a été rappelé
régulièrement par mes collègues
Christophe bechut et Caroline cailleux
sur tous les dispositifs que nous
continuerons à porter au bénéfice des
collectivités locales
[Applaudissements]
permettrait pourtant de changer la donne
alors que depuis 2017 ce ne sont pas
moins de 392 milliards de recettes
fiscales dont vous avez privé la nation
cette année avec votre volonté de
supprimer la CVAE vous persistez et vous
poursuivez votre stratégie des armement
fiscale monsieur le ministre il est
possible de réinvestir de manière juste
et efficace ces recettes supplémentaires
en y est intéressant mieux les
collectivités territoriales entendez
notre demande d'indexation la DGF
améliorer le bouclier énergétique pour
les collectivités accompagnés plus c'est
mieux les collectivités dans leurs
projets de transition écologique cc de
vouloir contrôler les dépenses des
collectivités monsieur le ministre il
est inconcevable alors que vous alors
que vous enregistrez ces 30 milliards de
recettes supplémentaires que de
nombreuses communes soient contraintes
de fermer des structures sportives et
culturelles de limiter l'éclairage
public d'augmenter les tarifs de
restauration scolaire de freiner leurs
investissements monsieur le ministre le
compte n'y est pas il est encore temps
de corriger la copie c'est ce que nous
vous invitons à faire lors l'examen du
PLF
la parole est à notre collègue Céline
voulait et stérodier pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
publics monsieur le ministre quand Annie
dalgo maire de Paris s'est présenté en
mars 2020 elle avait proclamé deux
engagements le premier était qu'elle ne
serait pas candidate à l'élection
présidentielle la France entière alors
constaté qu'elle n'avait pas tenu parole
le second engagement a été fait la main
sur le cœur jamais elle n'augmenterait
les impôts des Parisiens
oh non seulement elle l'a cessé de le
faire depuis 2014 mais cette semaine
coûte grasse les Parisiens apprennent
d'une manière pour le moins cavalière
qu'elle allait augmenter la taxe
foncière de plus de 50%, ceci pour
tenter de sortir Paris du chaos
économique dans lequel elle se trouve
la majorité de gauche avait pourtant
hérité ne vous en déplaise d'une
situation saine lors de l'alternance les
Parisiens sont excédés les services
publics ne sont pas à la hauteur d'une
grande métropole européenne Paris se
déplace cela étant dit cela étant dit
monsieur le ministre il n'est pas
envisageable que l'État en profite pour
porter atteinte aux libertés communales
et il n'est donc pas sérieux de parler
de mise sous tutelle
cependant il est temps que le Président
de la République s'intéresse au cœur de
la région capitale je souhaiterais donc
que vous m'indiquiez monsieur le
ministre par quelle mesure particulière
votre gouvernement compte soulager les
Parisiens qui devront de surcroît faire
des efforts dans la perspective des Jeux
olympiques de 2024
la parole est à au ministre délégué
chargé des forces publiques monsieur
Attal
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Boulay esperanier
quand je suis arrivé au ministère du
Budget il y a quelques mois j'ai
découvert que la Ville de Paris
bénéficiait d'un arrangement avec la
comptabilité publique négocier à
l'époque avec François Hollande appelée
système des loyers capitalisés qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire que la
Ville de Paris avait obtenu en 2015 le
droit d'endetter la ville en achetant
des logements en les confiant à des
bailleurs sociaux pour qu'il les
transforme et qui les entretiennent en
logements sociaux et en demandant au
bailleur de lui verser plusieurs
décennies de loyer à venir en une fois
pour équilibrer son budget de
fonctionnement je vous raconte ça
pourquoi madame la sénatrice d'abord
parce que j'ai décidé de mettre fin à ce
système qui était une véritable bombe à
retardement pour les parisiennes et pour
les parisiens
ensuite parce que cela dit tout de la
gestion budgétaire de la ville de Paris
par Madame Hidalgo et par son équipe la
réalité c'est que Madame Hidalgo
considère qu'elle est condamnée à taxer
plus parce qu'elle refuse de dépenser
moins et de maîtriser ses dépenses et de
faire des réformes à la ville de Paris
la réalité c'est que l'État est aux
côtés de la ville de Paris qu'il y a eu
encore des recettes exceptionnelles en
fiscalité cette année inversement
exceptionnel de 50 millions d'euros de
recettes de TVA il y a quelques semaines
que la Ville de Paris est d'ailleurs
éligible au filet de sécurité dont je
parlais tout à l'heure elle peut
bénéficier d'un acompte de 15 millions
d'euros mais l'État ne peut pas faire
les réformes nécessaires à la ville de
Paris à la place de la ville de Paris et
la réalité c'est que des réformes sont
possibles et sont nécessaires d'abord
appliquer vraiment les 35 heures pour
les fonctionnaires de la Ville de Paris
la ville a été condamnée à appliquée les
35 heures elle trouve tous les moyens de
contourner l'obligation légale des 35
heures arrêtez ensuite avec une
explosion des dépens discrétionnaire de
subventionnement à des associations
parfois faméliques ça aussi c'est
possible ça se décide ça nécessite du
courage politique tout ça pour vous dire
madame la sénatrice que le gouvernement
et que je serai toujours au côté des
parisiennes et des Parisiens ne
serait-ce que pour conduire la ville de
Paris et lui indiquer les réformes
nécessaires qui permettrait une gestion
saine des finances publiques
[Applaudissements]
je prends bien évidemment acte de ce que
vous venez de me dire je suis ravi de
nous partagerons la même analyse que
vous nous puissions travailler ensemble
à faire en sorte que Paris se porte
mieux bien entendu l'État n'est pas
comptable de cette situation par contre
je demande à l'état de s'intéresser
réellement aux Parisiens bien entendu la
question n'était pas facile puisque
municipales au régional les listes de la
majorité présidentielle avaient été
boudée mais depuis trois de vos
collègues trois députés de Paris sont
rentrés au gouvernement dans le
gouvernement de Madame Bank qui a
d'ailleurs travaillé à la mairie de
Paris je vous demande donc une vraie
vision pour les Parisiens que nous
aurons bien entendu ensemble
la parole est à notre collègue Stéphane
qui est noir pour le groupe les
républicains
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre il y a trois ans le groupe le
groupe les républicains marquaient son
profondes avec la réforme du
baccalauréat général et la disparition
programmée de l'enseignement des
mathématiques au lycée voulue par
Jean-Michel Blanquer à l'époque votre
majorité refusait de voir
là le déclin du niveau global en
mathématiques et le désintérêt dans
notre dans notre pays pour cette matière
et
voilà on compte à c'était un contraste
total avec
la croissance quasi exponentielle des
besoins de technologie dans notre pays
pour répondre aux besoins de la société
aujourd'hui vous entreprenez un travail
de déconstruction
des constructions de la réforme imposée
donc par votre prédécesseur en imposant
en déclarant que vous allez remettre un
enseignement de mathématiques dans le
tronc commun du lycée général
vous actez ainsi l'échec patant de la
réforme
sisnée et pardon
et je voulais dire oui ça nouveau
ça nouveau une pirouette qu'on pourrait
qualifier nous sort de rotation à 180
degrés pour rester dans le thème je me
félicite bien sûr de ce retour à la
raison un peu tardive de nature à
consolider aussi la culture scientifique
du plus grand nombre mais la mise en
œuvre pratique est encore pour le moins
confuse monsieur le ministre par exemple
disposeront nous de suffisamment de
professeurs pour assurer ses cours à la
rentrée et irez-vous jusqu'au bout du
raisonnement
en permettant de choisir un troisième
enseignement de spécialité en classe de
terminale
pour vous répondre la parole communiste
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur piennois
je partage bien entendu votre
préoccupation et votre intérêt pour le
niveau des mathématiques en France nous
sommes dans une situation paradoxale
puisque la France est un pays
d'excellence en mathématiques mais il a
eu 13 médailles et puis en même temps il
faut reconnaître que le niveau général
en mathématiques de la population et
notamment de la population scolaire a
baissé de manière importante ces
dernières années comme tous les
classements internationaux le démontre
nous avons donc réintroduit en effet
l'heure et demie une heure et demie de
mathématiques dans le tronc commun de
première en parallèle bien entendu des
élèves de première qui choisissent la
spécialité mathématique ils sont quand
même
64%. 7h30 vise à réconcilier en quelque
sorte les élèves qui sont fâchés et oui
avec les mathématiques mais aussi à leur
permettre d'accrocher l'option Matt
complémentaire en terminale aux côtés de
la spécialité maths et des maths exp
c'est un ensemble auquel nous ajoutons
un module de rattrapage pour les élèves
les plus en difficulté pour ceux qui
concerne la classe de seconde et un
certain nombre de dispositions clubs de
mathématiques au collège travail sur la
classe de 6e avec des mesures
spécifiques sur les mathématiques qui
seront annoncées en 6e voilà pour je
dirais le
les élèves non mathématiciens ou en tout
cas les élèves en difficulté et puis
nous travaillons aussi sur l'excellence
mathématique et là j'ai quelque chose
qui me tient à cœur et je sais que la
comme vous le savez la première ministre
y est particulièrement attaché elle qui
était en visite à l'école politique hier
pour le 50e anniversaire de l'entrée des
filles à l'école polytechnique c'est la
question de l'égalité fille garçon et de
la présence qui doit être largement
soutenu des filles en dans les filières
scientifiques et particulièrement en
mathématiques en classe de terminale
j'ai fait des précisions en ce sens en
disant que l'avenir de l'excellence
mathématique en France reposait en
grande partie sur les filles
le pied-noir c'est le Ministre trois ans
c'est le temps qu'il vous a fallu pour
corriger votre copie corriger vos
erreurs de calcul que de temps perdu
avec la politique du zigzag permanent
qui caractérise finalement votre
majorité depuis 2017 sur tant d'autres
sujets vous faites la démonstration si
j'ose dire que la ligne du gouvernement
est en fait une spirale une spirale
infernale dont les premières victimes
sont nos jeunes générations sacrifiés
sur le thème de vos atermoiements
successifs je ne me permettrai pas de
lui donner de vous commander mais
seulement de vous faire de vous donner
un petit conseil la prochaine fois
n'hésitez pas à écouter la parole du
Sénat merci
[Applaudissements]
nous en avons terminé que les questions
d'actualité merci madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres nos prochaines questions ont
lieu mercredi 23 novembre je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
16h30 pour l'examen du projet de loi de
finances rectificative pour 2022 la
séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance des questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement du Sénat
vous avez pu suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur notre antenne depuis 15h
et on a vu un parmi les moments forts le
7 séance aujourd'hui et cette série de
questions liées à la crise liée à
l'accueil de lotion Viking on a
d'ailleurs vu la tension montée au fil
des prises de parole avec au total pas
moins de 4 questions sur ce sujet on
retiendra par exemple cette question les
centrist sur la faiblesse de la réponse
européenne sur ce sujet et bien
d'ailleurs à la première ministre a
évoqué en réponse qu'un conseil européen
extraordinaire des ministres de
l'Intérieur allaient se tenir dans les
prochains jours à Bruxelles la pression
a continué de monter dans l'hémicycle
quand les écologistes se sont interrogés
sur les délais de traitement des
demandes d'asile de ces migrants de
lausan Viking évoquant une violation
même un de la Convention de Genève mais
l'acné de ces tensions on l'a vu au
moment des questions LR la droite avait
prévu d'ailleurs de poser en
enchaînement deux questions sur
l'immigration lors de la deuxième
question on a ainsi entendu les
sénateurs de gauche crier non mais c'est
une obsession écoutez un extrait de la
prise de parole d'Henri Leroy sénateur
LR des Alpes-Maritimes
la ministre combien faudra-t-il de
Bataclan de permettre de massacres de
Lola pour que vous puissiez enfin
la mesure du détail qui se joue sous les
yeux
qu'attendez-vous c'est d'accueillir sont
de l'isote ne veulent pas et pour
expulser tous ceux qui n'ont pas
vocation à être sur notre sol national
alors cette question immédiatement
provoquée la colère des élus de gauche
on les a vu depuis la tribune de presse
il tapait sur les tablettes ou des temps
en train de huer l'orateur c'est
oliveran qui a répondu votre question
est choquante et c'est un euphémisme
écoutez la suite je ne crois pas
je parle sous le contrôle de votre
président de groupe que je connais
suffisamment pour savoir que ça ne peut
pas être la ligne de la droite
républicaine de notre pays que celle de
faire le lien entre le terrorisme et le
sauvetage en mer de personnes qui si on
les avait pas accueilli en France faut
définir monsieur le sénateur parfait
rire en mer monsieur le sénateur je ne
sais pas si vous êtes amené à faire du
bateau si ça vous arrive pendant les
vacances ou autre mais j'ai une
conviction malgré la question que vous
avez posé c'est que si un jour vous
deviez vous trouver à côté d'un esquif
en pleine mer avec sur cette esquive des
personnes à bord et qui sont en train de
se noyer je ne crois pas que vous les
regarderiez les bras croisés en disant
vous n'avez pas de place sur notre
territoire vous viendriez évidemment les
aider et bien la France peut se
norgueillir de faire ce travail que
chaque citoyen ferait à sa place chaque
citoyen ferait sa place la
non-assistance à personne en danger
n'est pas dans l'ADN de la France n'est
pas dans l'ADN de la République et du
pays des Lumières monsieur le sénateur
voilà Olivier vérande qui à ce moment-là
était applaudi par toute la gauche de
l'hémicycle par les RDSE parler à l'rem
bien sûr et par certains centrist on
voit un Tam un sujet très clivant gauche
droite et qui a provoqué immédiatement
des direction très vive signe de
l'importance de ce débat autour de
l'accueil de la chaîne Viking dans cette
séance qui était on peut le dire
particulièrement mouvementé cette
semaine et oui effectivement à une
séance
très pour tous vos éclairages Quentin on
y a effectivement beaucoup parlé
notamment immigration on va débriefer ça
sur ce plateau dans un instant mais
d'abord et bien on va se rendre salle
des conférences un place aux réactions
et bien des sénateurs et des ministres
qui sont intervenus lors de cette séance
de questions au gouvernement et on va
retrouver tout de suite Hervé Marseille
au micro d'Alexandre poussin le
président du groupe Union centriste qui
a donc ouvert le bal des questions avec
une question sur l'immigration
comment vous réagissez quand vous
entendez un sénateur de droite faire le
lien entre le terrorisme le Bataclan et
l'immigration ce qui se passe sur le
chêne Viking je pense qu'on va beaucoup
trop loin c'est un sujet éminemment
compliqué complexe qui se prêtent à la
fois chez nous bien sûr mais aussi au
plan européen et on peut pas se
contenter de commentaires un peu
sommaire et simpliste sur le sujet ça
fait partie des dérives de la droite qui
durcit son discours sur l'immigration la
droite qui vous former la majorité ici
au Sénat c'est bien pour ça que je suis
au centre et que je ne partage pas
l'ensemble de cette forme d'expression
effectivement ce qu'on attend ce sont
des solutions pas nécessairement des
invectives ou des commentaires c'est ce
que j'ai essayé de poser sereinement à
la première ministre je suis pas eu
beaucoup de réponses mais je continue à
penser que il faut de la volonté il faut
de la fermeté mais il faut aussi des
accords avec les autres pays européens
et aujourd'hui malheureusement on est un
peu en jachère justement est-ce que vous
avez été convaincu par la réponse que
vous avez faite Elisabeth band la
première ministre sur les solutions à
apporter au niveau européen elle part
elle parle d'un futur pacte européen sur
l'Asie et l'immigration mais pour
l'instant on en est loin mais il existe
depuis 2020 ce pacte sur l'asile et
l'immigration mais aujourd'hui ne
fonctionne pas il y a un mécanisme de
solidarité volontaire qui fonctionne mal
également donc il faut que ça marche
mais on parle pas aux autres on
s'engueule avec eux on donne des leçons
on menace les Italiens on parle plus aux
Allemands à l'extérieur on est en froid
avec les Marocains les pays d'Afrique
nous mettent dehors moi je sais pas
comment on fait pour renvoyer les gens
dans leur pays si on discute pas avec
les pays d'origine et puis les autres
Européens si on veut trouver des
compromis il faut parler avec eux
aujourd'hui soit on donne des cours de
morale comme hongrois et au Polonais
soit on menace comme avec les Italiens
il faut se mettre autour de la table et
chercher des compromis et c'est au
niveau de l'Europe qu'on pourra trouver
des mécanismes c'est long c'est
difficile mais il faut le faire il y a
une forme d'hypocrisie des pays
européens qui ne sont pas les plus
proches des côtes africaines et qui
n'accueillent pas ne relocalise pas
forcément ces migrants c'est encore une
fois c'est un sujet complexe on peut pas
se contenter du Yaka faucon on sait très
bien que c'est très compliqué il y a des
pays comme l'Allemagne qui ont besoin de
main d'oeuvre qui sont pas pressés de
fermer leur frontières et on sait très
bien que ce sont les mêmes pays qui
accueillent les migrants comme l'Italie
on voit le résultat au niveau
gouvernemental et l'Espagne aussi donc
il faut aider ces pays il faut que nous
partageons le fardeau et pas seulement
se passer les difficultés comme une
patate chaude on a le dialogue européen
c'est la solution merci beaucoup Hervé
Marseille a d'être venu au micro Public
Sénat merci merci beaucoup
aléros cette première réaction et lors
de ce débrie c'est bien on va enchaîner
les réactions autour de cette séance au
mouvementée de questions au gouvernement
et il y a notamment un autre sujet qui a
marqué cette séance et celui de la
laïcité celui du port de la Baia dans
les établissements scolaires et
d'ailleurs vous êtes avec le ministre de
l'éducation nationale pas peine direct
c'est à VOUS Alexandre effectivement on
va parler de la laïcité à l'école mais
d'abord monsieur le ministre une
réaction sur l'immigration je rappelle
vous avez dirigé le Musée national de
l'immigration à Paris quand vous
entendez un sénateur de droite faire le
lien entre terrorisme et migration
comment vous réagissez je réagis en
étant à la fois scandalisé et attristé
que l'on puisse faire le lien entre un
bateau de migrants dont 44 enfants y
compris des enfants de moins de 3 ans
des bébés de quelques mois et puis
l'atroce attentat du Bataclan il y a 7
ans ce type d'arguments ou de raccourcis
ne fait pas honneur à la vie politique
française alors cet après-midi vous avez
été interrogé notamment sur la laïcité à
l'école avec des alertes sur le port de
tenue musulmane dans les collèges et
dans les lycées concrètement pourquoi
a-t-on le droit de rentrer dans un
collège avec et bien une tenue
religieuse comme la Baya ou le camis on
n'a pas le droit d'entrer dans un
établissement scolaire avec une tenue à
intention religieuse la loi de 2004 est
très claire à ce sujet et par conséquent
c'est la loi et les circulaires qui
s'appliquent d'abord une concertation
avec l'élève et la famille
éventuellement une sanction et s'il y a
lieu la protection des personnels
concernés mais concrètement dans
l'exemple du lycée de Montauban c'est
jeune fille sont rentrés avec des tenues
religieuses dans l'enceinte de
l'établissement il y avait une vingtaine
de jeunes filles portant des tenues
appelées à Baya avant les vacances
d'automne une concertation s'est engagée
avec les familles de manière à ce que
environ 16 d'entre elles retirent les
vêtements incriminés il en restait 4 à
la rentrée l'une c'est radicalisée et à
d'elle-même l'établissement avant qu'une
procédure soit engagée contre elle par
conséquent ce que cette affaire du lycée
Bourdel des montres c'est que la loi de
2004 est appliquée c'est que les
circulaires permettent de résoudre et
d'avancer sur ces situations on applique
la loi 2004 mais on les laisse quand
même rentrer dans l'établissement et
après on entame un dialogue on laisse
rentrer dans l'établissement de manière
à ce qu'elle puisse dialoguer avec le
chef d'établissement mais je répète que
des vêtements à intention religieuses ne
sont pas autorisées dans ce lycée comme
dans tous les autres alors vous avez
décidé le retour des